we have breaking news on a missing woman
in Iowa the search for 20 year-old Molly
Tibbets who disappeared nearly five
weeks ago apparently has led to her body
the University of Iowa student was last
seen alive on July 18th sources tell CBS
News Tibbets has been found dead but
very few details are available at this
time
Adriana Diaz has covered this story
since it began and is talking with her
sources in Iowa she's with us from
Chicago
Adriana a very tough morning for her
family very tough morning indeed nor
this is a heartbreaking end to this saga
surrounding the missing-persons case of
Molly Tibbets she disappeared just over
a month ago when she went on her daily
jog in her hometown of Brooklyn Iowa
this is a tiny town in a very rural area
that the landscape is difficult and
that's something that investigators told
us was a real challenge in their search
for her because they had to go through
cornfields they had to use drones to try
to take a peek at this farmland that's
very hard to get through molly was a
light and everyone we spoke to in her
hometown and even beyond her hometown
people were talking about her they said
that she would brighten anyone's day
that she had no enemies she was a friend
to everyone and there were photos of her
all around this town Brooklyn Iowa was
wallpapered with photos of Molly Tibbets
because everyone was searching for her
this was a cause her community took on
the nation took on this story has really
captivated the country and the fact that
we know now that she has been found and
we know now that she's found dead is
going to be heartbreaking for people
across the country in addition to her
family y know and I know that you've
been talking to her family for weeks and
that they were holding out hope that
this wouldn't be the outcome that's
right we spoke to her mother her father
her father told us that that he believed
at the time that she went willingly with
someone that perhaps she met online that
she and this person had had left their
hometown and that she and that person
were then in over their heads that they
had no way to return especially now
then when the story had become so huge
so he was really just begging her to
come back that it's okay that you know
that they love her no matter what
because he was holding out hope that she
was alive and there were so many
mysteries surrounding the story the
investigators really weren't able to
give much information on what they were
finding but there were no real updates
about evidence that they found or
anything like that so it was so
mysterious that her family believed she
must have gone willingly because there
were no signs of a struggle she was
staying at her boyfriend's house Dalton
she was dog sitting that night there was
no break-in there were no signs that she
left under duress she went for her jog
she never came back and as you remember
she was wearing her Fitbit she had her
cell phone so they use that information
to try to track her location and Adriana
what about a suspect we will find out
from authorities I'm sure later today
about a suspect about who might be
involved who they may or may not have in
custody
but it's unclear right now at this point
whether she was taken whether she left
and something happened to her but we
will be hearing from authorities later
today the police are expected to hold a
news conference at 6:00 p.m. Eastern
Time later tonight obviously not the
outcome anybody had been hoping for and
our thoughts are with her family Adriana
thank you